depression is a debilitating medical
illness that according to the National
Institutes of Health affects 8.4 percent
of adults in the U.S since the beginning
of the 20th century treatments for
depression changed with each new decade
at the turn of the century Depression
was seen as a mental sickness and
patients were admitted to mental asylums
in the 1930s Depression was treated with
electroshock therapy in the 1940s
lobotomies were sometimes used for
severe depression it wasn't until the
1960s that cognitive therapy gained
traction leading psychologists to study
brain chemistry and Physiology as a
cause of depression and not just a
behavioral anomaly in the 1980s a new
class of drugs called ssris were
released on the market they were seen as
a Wonder pill that corrected the
chemical imbalance in the brains of the
depressed recently this long-held theory
of depression being caused by a chemical
imbalance has lost support among
psychologists as it lacks significant
evidence what more ssris are still being
prescribed to treat a cause of
depression that doesn't exist and in
some cases does more harm than good in
this video I'll be discussing the dark
science of ssris
foreign
[Music]
ton is a neurotransmitter that regulates
numerous processes in the body such as
sleep memory attention body temperature
and most importantly mood SSRI stands
for a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor as the name implies ssris
inhibit the reuptake of Serotonin when
your body releases serotonin it binds to
receptors and is then retaken up back
into the neuron from which it came ssris
block the reuptake channels thereby
increasing the amount of time that
serotonin binds to receptors because
serotonin has a hand in maintaining mood
the idea is if someone is depressed they
just need more serotonin to make them
feel happy if increasing a
neurotransmitter to make someone happy
sounds overly simplistic that's because
it is the origin of the chemical
imbalance Theory dates back to a time
when Psychiatry was trying to explain
mental illness through a lens of
biochemistry two separate discoveries in
the 20th century when Alt ultimately
lead psychologists to adopting the
chemical and balance Theory to explain
and treat depression the first discovery
occurred in 1952 at Staten Island Sea
View Hospital a sanatorium for
tuberculosis cases doctors began
treating tuberculosis patients with an
experimental drug called ipronazade
which increased monoamine
neurotransmitters monoamine
neurotransmitters like dopamine
norepinephrine and serotonin are broken
down by enzymes as part of a biological
process when taken ipronazate inhibits
these enzymes thereby keeping
neurotransmitters around longer and
increasing their effects
due to the nature of tuberculosis
infections patients had long stays at
sanatoriums from several weeks to months
making them lethargic and depressed
however doctors quickly noted that when
patients were given nipronazade their
mood became very positive and active due
to the increase in monoamine
neurotransmitters doctors deduce that a
patient's mood could be improved if
certain neurotransmitters were altered
in the body however ipronazade was
discontinued in 1961 for being linked to
hepatitis the second Discovery would
come more than a decade later a 1967
study published in the British Journal
of Psychiatry reported that people with
depression had lower serotonin levels
than normal this was found when
serotonin samples were recovered from
the brains of individuals who had
committed
researchers found them to have lower
serotonin levels than non-depressed
people with these two discoveries
psychologists came to the conclusion
that Depression was a biochemical
phenomenon and pharmaceutical companies
aptly responded to that claim but first
a word from today's sponsor private
internet access VPN a VPN or virtual
private network is a service that
encrypts your internet connection and
hides your IP address with a VPN like
Pia not even your internet service
provider can see your private info or
the websites you visited also Pia does
not store your data their no logs policy
has been proven in court you can also
change what country you're in giving
access to more streaming content you can
choose from 84 countries plus all 50
states Pia also offers P2P file sharing
and is one of the few vpns to do so this
video took about 30 hours to make so
when I finally posted it it was time to
relax unfortunately one of my favorite
TV shows the office is only available on
Netflix in the UK with private internet
Access VPN I just changed my location to
the UK and I'm watching the office
it's compatible with Windows Mac OS iOS
Android Linux and more and there are no
limits to how many devices you can use
with a single subscription pia has over
30 million downloads and has been rated
excellent on trustpilot dark science
viewers can get 83 off plus four extra
months free that's just two dollars and
three cents a month signing up is risk
free with a 30-day money-back guarantee
and 24 7 customer support sign up via
the link in the description below
from a pharmaceutical perspective if
Depression was purely an issue of low
serotonin The Cure was to increase it by
the early 1970s Eli Lilly made the first
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor
Prozac by 1988 it was being sold in
pharmacies across the country and the
rest is history today the low serotonin
or chemical imbalance theory has come
under scrutiny and very few
psychologists if any openly supported in
July 2022 a study from the Journal of
molecular Psychiatry performed a
meta-analysis on 361 different studies
on whether a correlation was made
between depression and low serotonin the
study concluded there was no connection
whatsoever between depression and
serotonin
experiments were even done where patient
serotonin levels were artificially
lowered by removing tryptophan a
serotonin precursor from their diet even
with artificially reduced serotonin
patients did not show signs of
depression or change in mood what does
this mean for people taking ssris ssris
increased serotonin but as we've seen
increasing serotonin is not addressing
the problem however ssris do have some
benefits explaining why they're still
being used today psychologists and even
some patients state that ssris work for
them by numbing feelings of anxiety for
someone with severe OCD panic disorder
social anxiety or PTSD this numbing
effect can be a major relief from a
medical standpoint even if ssris are not
treating the cause of depression per se
it's better to have a mild indifference
to depression than to Take It On full
bore but there's also a downside the
effect of blunting depression is advised
for those with severe depression or
major depressive disorder people with
mild to moderate depression who take
ssris numb The Valleys of depression but
also the peaks of happiness or just wipe
out their emotions altogether this
sounds dramatic but it's how some people
have described their experience here are
some confessionals from people on the
subreddit r- antidepressants talking
about the negative impact ssris have had
on their lives
you don't feel bad anymore you don't
feel good but you didn't before so it's
not that bad you feel like a zombie you
act like a zombie you feel dull and slow
and sluggish when someone screams in
your face you barely register but it
felt different than before it works and
it doesn't work
over time they make me feel lethargic
and emotionally numb when I quit I had
severe withdrawal for eight months and
developed pssd so I may have dysfunction
for life
some have made my emotions feel
smothered in plastic wrap like I know
they're under there but they're totally
suffocated and I can't access them it's
an unsettling feeling when I'm super
depressed sometimes my feelings will be
blunted but I don't even care
ssris blunting emotions can be very
beneficial for people with major
depressive disorder for struggles with
day-to-day living but for mild or
moderate depressive cases this emotional
dampening can be less beneficial this
isn't just an opinion among adversely
affected patients and Skeptics in 2008
Irving cursed a psychology professor at
Harvard University published results of
a controversial study on antidepressant
effects submitted to the FDA in
comparing Placebo effects to
antidepressants Kirsch found that ssris
only benefit those with severe
depression and not those with mild or
moderate depression the basis for this
was that in mild to moderate cases the
placebo worked just as well or sometimes
better than the SSRI it was only in
severe cases that ssris performed
significantly better than the placebo
Kirsch concluded that the unwanted side
effects cause more risk than reward for
patients with mild or moderate
depression in 2019 the Royal College of
psychiatrists stated that the route teen
use of antidepressants for mild
depressive symptoms is not generally
recommended this recommendation pertains
to the harsh negative effects that may
cause more detriment to someone who is
mildly or moderately depressed one
well-known side effect of ssris is
post-ssris dysfunction or pssd symptoms
of pssd are decreased libido failure to
reach climax impedance and even numbness
of the genitals one study from the
Journal of sex and marital therapy ran a
double-blind test where 344 participants
were given ssris they found 58 percent
of the 344 participants presented
symptoms of pssd a separate study from
the journal of clinical Psychiatry found
the prevalence of pssd to be between 25
and 73 percent of SSRI users there is
even a subreddit called r slash pssd
where users share their experience while
taking or coming of ssris
another side effect that's been very
controversial and for good reason is
increased aggression from ssris with an
increase in machines in the last two
decades some groups have tried to blame
this pattern on ssris this is because
some Studies have linked increased
aggression and dissociation which may
influence while the correlation to mesh
and ssris has been disproven there are
some studies that have found a slight
increase in aggression while on ssris a
2006 study from the medical journal plus
medicine concluded that ssris cause a
slight increase in aggression compared
to Placebo in the study 13 000
participants were divided into two
groups one group was given Placebo and
the other was given an SSRI called
paroxetine following behavioral tests
and general observation the SSRI group
showed a two-fold increase in aggression
compared to the placebo group however
the prevalence for aggression in both
groups was less than one percent with
0.31 percent of placebo showing
aggressive behavior versus 0.65 percent
in the SSRI group though the prevalence
was very rare there was a marked
increase in aggression in the SSRI group
lastly one of the most serious side
effects that turned the FDA upside down
is the increased risk of Tendencies
while on ssris according to 2004 FDA
clinical trials suicidal Behavior
increased by 80 percent for users under
25 years of age within the first two
months of starting ssris however it is
firmly noted that after this initial
exposure users overcame this intense
period and no longer had ideation after
two months yet in 2006 the FDA required
the infamous Black Box warning label on
36 SSRI drugs stating it may cause
suicidal ideation the Black Box label is
the most severe warning the FDA can
place on a drug just short of banning it
it's clear that ssris are not ideal for
people who don't have severe depression
still mild and moderate depression can
be debilitating and may need medication
recently neuroscientists have looked
into psilocybin the active in ingredient
in psychedelic mushrooms as an
alternative fmri scans have shown brain
connections being rebuilt after taking
psilocybin fmri scans show metabolic
activity in the brain By changes in
blood flow in this fmri parts of the
brain that are yellow and orange signify
more blood flow and therefore increased
activity by contrast parts that are blue
show decreased activity When comparing a
depressed brain and non-depressed brain
you can see the depressed brain has less
activity than the non-depressed brain
does its theorized depression may change
networks in the brain that help us to
process stress and emotions brain scans
have shown reduced activity in the
amygdala and prefrontal cortex of
depressed people the amygdala processes
emotions in the prefrontal cortex
interprets those emotions through
logical understanding reduced activity
in these regions hinder the ability to
logically process emotions and adapt to
stress however fmri scans taken after
consuming psilocybin show these regions
to have increased activity in a 2017
study from the journal Nature medicine
patients with major depressive disorder
who were resistant to ssris were split
into two groups one group was given
daily doses of psilocybin and the other
an SSRI called escitalopram for six
weeks fmri scans were performed at the
start of the study and three weeks after
its completion fmri scans showed higher
interconnections between brain networks
for the psilocybin group and no change
in brain Network organization in the
escitalopram group in questionnaire
responses the psilocybin group had a 50
Improvement five weeks after the trial
ended in contrast the escatelprem group
had higher depression scores and less
brain activity the study concluded that
psilocybin had Global increases in brain
Network integration which helped provide
a better antidepressant response
recently this therapy has begun to gain
more attraction among the public and
medical professionals however due to
psilocybin being classified as a
schedule one drug it's difficult to
obtain for research and study its
long-term effects so what about the
future of ssris psychologists and
psychiatrists agree that though ssris
are treating symptoms of an illness that
does not exist in the eyes of science
they still provide relief ssris are not
the best treatment for mild and moderate
depression but doctors do agree that
they're better than no treatment
psychology researcher Mark Horowitz who
came out against the chemical imbalance
Theory and discussed issues with ssris
with Insider magazine stated that
numbing effect can be very relieving for
people if you are in complete strife and
everything's a panic then being a bit
numbed probably comes as a great relief
however Horowitz admits that researchers
need to learn more about depression to
properly treat it
thank you for watching this episode of
dark science
foreign
[Music]